bei mir im studio jetzt profiler markt
hier hoffmann und zusammen schauen wir
gleich auf die psyche des täters vorher
schauen wir aber nochmal auf den ort des
geschehens wo die drei unfälle
nacheinander passiert sind auf den
berliner stadtring wir sehen uns hier
der erste crash im bereich der
innsbrucker brücke der zweite in der
detmolder straße und der dritte am
tempelhofer feld und wie schon
angesprochen markt hier hofft man jetzt
bei mir profiler und kriminal analyst
herr hoffmann sie haben es gehört sie
haben es gesehen sie kennen ihn fallen
ein bisschen fangen wir doch mal mit
einer einfachen frage an es wird jetzt
als terroranschlag eingestuft es
vermischt sich aber auch so ein bisschen
mit einem amoklauf wo sind die grenzen
ja das ist keine einfache frage sondern
eine sehr sehr schwierige auch wenn das
wort terror seit sehr langer zeit jetzt
auch in der öffentlichkeit verwendet
wird und es gab auch eigene terror
experten gibt die es quasi
hauptberuflich machen auch in der
wissenschaft extremismus forschung ist
alles nichts neues mehr und dennoch gibt
es bis heute keine einheitliche
international schon gar nicht
akzeptierte definition für terrorismus
früher waren die grenzen mal relativ
klar das war gibt es keine einheitliche
definition aber der kleinste gemeinsame
nenner kann man doch sagen war früher
mal die abgrenzung terrorist politisch
ideologisch oder religiös motiviert und
meistens das werk einer organisation zb
nine eleven und amok ist psychologisch
persönlich motiviert und er das werk von
einzeltätern das heißt amok ist
persönlich terror ist politisch das
waren mal recht klare grenzen
doch was ist jetzt wenn jemand sage ich
mal persönliche probleme hat
beispielsweise die freundin trennt sich
jobverlust also wieder antrag abgelehnt
was auch immer geht dann los begeht
taten und ruft dabei allahu akbar
ja was ist das denn jetzt eigentlich ist
das amok oder ist dass terrorismus
es ist nicht ganz klar zu definieren
anhand der vorher bestehenden grenzen
das heißt man muss erstmal hinnehmen
dass wir es hier mit einem neuen
kriminalitätsphänomen zu tun haben und
die grenzen zwischen amok und
terrorismus verschwimmen
das gilt für die taten berliner
breitscheidplatz oder die tat in limburg
manchmal ist das amok manchmal
rechtsextremistisch manchmal manchmal
islamistisch motiviert aber sowohl die
tatmittel als auch die täterprofile sind
immer ähnlich
klar und gerade dieses phänomen der lone
wolf terror ist also der der
terroristischen einzeltäter ist von
amokläufern teilweise gar nicht mehr
abzugrenzen oder wenn dann nur sehr sehr
schwer
ich will nur ein beispiel nennen 2016
attentat münchner olympiazentrum mobbing
wurde drei jahre lang als motiv genannt
wurde als amoktat betrachtet drei jahre
später hat das lka dieser einschätzung
korrigiert und doch von politischen
motiven gesprochen und in dem fall von
hanau hatte die tagesschau getitelt
rechte tat aber kein rechter täter
fragezeichen das heißt auch da war die
frage ja ist ja nun rechtsextrem oder
nicht ich habe mist bekennervideo damals
auch angeschaut und vollkommen klar
mischen sich absolut rassistische
theorien wird verschwörungstheorien klar
eine psychische erkrankung er spricht
von verfolgungswahn der täter von hanau
wohl bemerkt was ich damit sagen will
ist dass in der jüngeren vergangenheit
ist immer wieder taten gab bei den amok
und terror sich auf einer art entgrenzte
dass es nicht mehr klar weder juristisch
noch psychologisch auseinander zeiten
ist